I've hacked the game Pokemon go without
moving it's possible I've done it boys
the scientific breakthrough is finally
here in closing I'm about to walk to
that gym without walking look a [ __ ]
face I'm going I'm walking it's for
[ __ ] losers we hacked the game it
took a long time but with my hacking
skills I finally managed to do it but
we're not stopping here baby
let's hack some more
heck wall now y'all seen drones
but a great way to get a hack done is to
take your
it worked heck hack too
not even Trump's wall could suck this
let's drop this hack is called the dog
you get a piece of string
we couldn't find a straightness and we
got it's got a cable our phone is on
this end and then Edgar's color is on
this end but finally this [ __ ] shitty
investment is going to pay off all right
you hear me now catch me some Pokemon go
you trying to plate just go what this
hack does is that it collects the GPS
points of cracking eggs so hopefully we
will get a 10k egg pretty soon I think I
feel one hatching right now I think this
piece of [ __ ] dog would move [ __ ]
give me T Martin's dog what the [ __ ]
kind of [ __ ] of dog is this
don't pretend that you don't hear me
hope thirsty was he do Jesus
okay did you crack the egg he got it
we got a Pikachu back free you feel me
try it so hard
balloon phone that's original there's
been speculations that you can catch
legendary Pokemon you gotta go higher so
with this hack balloon pact that we
developed we are going to fly get me
them YouTube give me them you to get
Landon
this hack you can get a lot of distance
fast for those really nice eggs next egg
you
we hacked Pokemon go it has never been
done before by anyone ever look at me
look at me go
catching all the pokemons I got an even
better hack for you just go outside
thanks for watching guys leave a like if
you enjoyed leave our thumbs up and I'll
see you bros in the next video
give me my [ __ ] chair is there I mean
now we're gonna get over there there we
go
next egg can we make it this thumb go
like up your dress yeah I'll pull it out
Oh NYX hey yeah we're good that's gonna
be the [ __ ] file item oh my god
next hand